pas mon pinceau 22e
et j'accueille dj will
ce qui veut dire à nos amis du
spectateur sait que dj will alias
william est non seulement le producteur
de notre ami chris begin mais en plus
vous avez fait vous les connards le
groupe les connards vous avez fait le
les bratisla boys voilà vous êtes le le
musicien de michaël youn l'hiver ça
mark recchi séguin
krikor bravo
un point pour frédéric beigbeder 10 père
paul harris a commencé cette personne a
des gars à penser ça fait un point pour
frédéric beigbeder voilà will à toi l'a
si bien dit prime ce cas du prix
québec baie des jackson five bravo
c'est parti très vite deux points pour
l'équipe de beigbeder un point pour
l'équipe de laurent baffie attention je
veux l'interprète dj will
alors on a vu où iron marvin gaye
bradent leurs ans et luisa c'est louise
qui a soufflé voilà attention à vous dis
oui
je vous promets
ah ah
faux
il ya eu tellement soufflage que le
point n'ira nulle part c'est un petit
peu ridicule
il faut pas soufflé fond plat soufflé
donc on reste à 2 2 a vous dit oui à une
rigueur l'en but
j'ai bien réussi
les rolling stones voilà bravo enfin
frédéric attention jeudi dans deux ou
jean way
et
à pékin pour l'équipe l'on me dit oui
une
pas sur place madeleine bratislava il
est vrai s'est essoufflé
c'était son fait le point dans la
vive secteur
ça fait quatre points pour l'équipe de
laurent baffie trois points pour
l'équipe de frédéric beigbeder avoue dj
will un nom
et l'on évite lycée alors les cultures
les langues vernaculaires connais la
bravo laurent voilà c'est bien tout le
monde en parle a choisi
ouais
j'en ai marre
et voilà c'est un point donc c'est tom
jones et c'est encore un point je prends
l'équipe de laurent baffie avoue dj will
6 3
m
oui
melzer alors la cdu maintenant si
vraiment je demande la concentration
parce que c'est la fin du par équipes
c'est chacun pour sa gueule depuis le
début depuis le début c'est comme ça à
mellac deux là là si tu veux c'est
vraiment chacun pour sa gueule là c'est
le lit l'ultra libéralisme n'a plus
d'amis les gens demandent pourquoi parce
que la vie est injuste
voilà trois galles for life sera gueule
fort l'âge absolument frigide
attention je veux l'interprète
vous n'avez plus d'amis là d'accord vous
n'a jamais non jamais attendant mois
séparés sainte notion dj will
oui
l'euro
et d'abord au maire
suivant maintenant on passe au mega man
show
bien bâle où j'avais déjà deux points
lolo maintenant attention passe à
l'ultra bon qu attention dj will la
carac chanté par john wayne simmonds
ces moments là maintenant on arrive au
dernier
et là c'est très très fort attention
très très difficile
ouais
m
quoi qu'on devient pelouse vaillant a
emporté ce faire non non et dissout
qu'il a dit dr dre gg c'est méchant du
dit d'observer et si j'accepte que lou
remporte la partie
c'est le noyau des membres d'un parti
voilà merci à tous
c'était tout le monde en parlant c'était
tout bon l'ambiance c'était tout le
monde arabe il reste plus que 2 après
c'est la quille bordel
ah ouais après un pic de la presse télé
vacants et arbitres d'attendre le mois
de septembre
attention ça va être dur mais bon c'est
combien qui fait les deux derniers actes
c'était sûrement pas avec jean marie
danièle gilbert le single s'appelle si
la ferme c'est david grands airs jazzy
double zéro de gea pires avec erika jean
edouard baer sortie le 7 choix l'album
avec l'anaconda bellouet ce beau mot
sorti le 15 juin
jean charpak soyez sa bande les
prophètes avec volant mais c'est édité
chez odile jacob connect et les clippers
sont restées normales sabres ont fait
chez dargaud chalmont marraine de
l'opération photos de stars vendredi
le 15 juin à 19 heures au grand côté
vous écris tu vois là et merci
au mac os pour le chien luis fernandez
le single s'appelle maurice takacs il
sort le 29 juin luc doyon bravo bravo
google est devenu en 20 ans le basque à
logis avec m
nouaille à 10,2
3 sur le single s'appelle de vie rails
on sera pas ce que ça veut dire sorti mi
juillet
basile de koch président barroso j'ai dû
créé par an et chez jean claude lattès
la crise vide
ch
voilà alors l'association juge pour le
single agir et agir qu'au profit de
nous c'est ma au maroc les fonds seront
reversés ou ce faux formulaires france
et voilà c'était le monde en parle
bruxelles y voit le jour
quoique
sow
hu
tous deux
m
la syrie
actu
le nom